you know i do things a little
differently here i do things a little
differently on my radio show and
other platforms and that's this
i don't just comment i don't just
observe
i get dirt under my fingernails what do
i mean by that
i'm an activist
and i'm mission oriented
i'm an activist and a mission oriented
eight months ago before the release of
american marxism
i got on the radio and here and i made
it clear that we had to build a movement
we had to build a movement to confront
these various aspects of american
marxism
critical race theory and the destruction
of our classrooms the de-growth movement
under the rubric of climate change and
the the war on capitalism
this transgender movement and so forth
that these were destroying our country
we looked at other issues too of course
open borders and the the attack on
separation of powers on the independence
of the courts and on and on and on
this is the modern day democrat party it
is the
the model through which american marxism
represents itself and you can see the
media today the media today celebrate
defend and promote these various
movements
critical race theory first they deny it
exists and then they say what are you
scared of it why cancel it
same with the uh the the degrowth
movement the world on capitalism and on
and on and on
and so we have people politicians in
washington we have hosts on radio and tv
are trying to figure out what happened
this week
in the election
well what happened was this
a movement was building very very
quietly under the radar
millions and millions of people were
involved
millions of people who read american
marxism who listened to talk radio
millions of people who've had enough of
what's going on in washington and the
personal effect it has on them whether
it's inflation the price of groceries
the price of gasoline
and this talk about fundamentally
transitioning our economic system to
something else
and this talk about white racism and
white supremacy day in and day out
people are sick and tired of the whole
thing
now there were two things that could
have happened
we could have rolled over we could have
rolled over it been in a fetal position
and let that happen
or fight back and push back
eight months ago it seemed that many of
us were prepared to surrender
many of us were what was me many of us
didn't know what to do
but we galvanized and we rallied this is
something we talked about on the show
day in and day out it's something i've
talked about on radio day in and day out
even if we have certain differences
among us
those of us who love this country
those of us who believe in its founding
those of us who believe in the
declaration of independence and
unalienable rights those of us who
believe in the constitution of the bill
of rights
we had to come together we had to unite
despite our differences despite if we're
in one party or another or no party to
push back against these american marxist
movements that had been leaching into
our kids schools leaching into the media
leeching into the public square
or they were going to defeat us that we
had to claw our way back one election at
a time one battle at a time one school
system at a time
that's what happened last week
that's what happened last week and i
might add with no help
from washington dc in the establishment
this is a grassroots movement
grassroots movement
the reagan revolution was a grassroots
movement opposed by the republican
establishment it took reagan three times
before he became the nominee and one of
the most successful presidents in
american history the rise of the tea
party movement when i wrote the book
liberty and tyranny they came out
simultaneously the tea party movement
which gave a majority to the house
republicans
almost took over the senate as well and
was opposed and fought by the republican
establishment and their uh and their
surrogates in the media
the trump revolution
which completely changed our politics
still opposed by established republicans
and the so-called never-trumpers and so
forth
now we have this movement
you and i we are part of this movement
we're not just observers we're not just
commentators looking back 2020 over our
shoulder to well what happened last week
we know what happened last week we were
personally involved in it what happened
last week is simple
we are not going to allow this country
to fall to these american marxist
movements why do i call them american
marxist movements because they're
founders they're scholars they're pseudo
intellectuals they're advocates they're
activists
they call it marxist movements we saw
what happened two summers ago in our
streets to our cities we saw what they
did to our police forces from sea to
shining sea
we saw how they tried to overturn this
country
turn it inside out turn it into a
country we would not even recognize
destroying it from within
and when we had an opportunity to push
back we push back we push back in our
school systems we're pushing back with
this monstrous bill
that biden pelosi and schumer want to
push through that will fundamentally
alter our government and our economic
system we are pushing back and we must
continue to push back
these american marxists they're awake 24
7 trying to figure out how to sabotage
this nation
we have to continue to be resolute
fantastic election night the other night
from virginia new jersey new york
pennsylvania texas colorado kansas
throughout the country school boards
local sheriff's elections
big victories
but they're just victories last week we
need to build on this we need to go on
offense we need to put them on their
heels they need to respond to us
have you seen the media
the media have now turned on
quote-unquote white women in the suburbs
two elections ago they couldn't slobber
over them enough because they were
voting for biden they thought
well now in virginia and in new jersey
they didn't they voted against the
democrats in order to protect their
children their flesh and blood from this
american marxist movement called
critical race theory what do the media
say oh these are racist white women in
the suburbs now
everybody's racist of course
but the racists the people who push
critical racist theory they're the
racists the people in the media
especially msnbc and cnn
racist professors racist activists
racist hosts day in and day out and what
do they do righteous people who believe
in diversity who have no problem with
people of other faiths and backgrounds
and pigmentation and so forth you are
the ones who they demonize and attack
and one other thing about what took
place last week
the relentless attacks on donald trump
they completely backfired
terry mcauliffe the former bag man for
the clintons terry mcauliffe could not
say donald trump's name enough and for
most of the campaign almost right up to
the end he was running against donald
trump nice try terry guess what you lost
and donald trump won
donald trump won
your
attempt to turn this into a trump race
you lost
now glenn younkin and the team over
there ran a fantastic campaign as they
did in new jersey as they did all over
the country
we must embrace this country our
founding our patriotism
push back against what's taking place
and that's exactly what is happening i
want to remind you albeit briefly of
what i said in the first chapter of
american marxism which has now sold
almost 1.2 million copies
during this summer during the lead up to
this victory where millions of you have
read it have passed along the message
have been the paul reveres the paul
reveres throughout this country under
the radar
unrecognized by the establishment
politicians in washington but you know
who you are i know who you are
first chapter american marxism american
marxism has made great progress toward
instituting its goals over the last
several years if it is to be defeated as
it must albeit a daunting and complex
mission its existence must first be
acknowledged and labeled for what it is
the urgency of the moment must be
realized in the emergence of a unified
patriotic front a previously docile
divergent and or disputatious societal
cultural and political factions and
forces which have in common their belief
that america is worth defending must
immediately galvanize around and rally
to the cause we must rise to the
challenge as did our founding fathers
when they confronted the most powerful
force on earth that's right the british
empire and defeated it admittedly in
numerous ways today's threat is more
byzantine as it now inhabits most of our
institutions and menaces from within
making engagement difficult and
complicated nonetheless
i fervently believe america as we know
it will be forever lost if we do not
prevail well guess what
red-blooded americans of all colors and
all backgrounds who love this country
whether born citizens or naturalized
citizens or soon-to-be naturalized
citizens
have had enough
and we are standing up to this
not because washington says so not
because certain media are reporting on
it but because you are taking matters
into your own hands and you will
continue to be trashed by the corrupt
media in this country you will continue
to be trashed by the corrupt democrat
party in this country as well as other
establishmentarians but keep up the
fight we've got a long way to go a long
way to go not just in our schools but in
our corporations in our colleges and
universities
defending the police defending the
military securing the border getting our
constitution back fighting off the
effort to destroy separation of powers
and the independence of the courts this
is our mission these are the forces that
we are up against
and i could not be more proud
of you the american people
who are saying this is my country
regardless of your background in your
race
and i'm going to defend it and look at
who won in virginia
a white governor
a black lieutenant governor
and a brown attorney general
and guess what
the media in this country are calling
them racists
racists well let me tell you something
the media in this country are racists
they're bigots they're anti-semites they
are liars and they are corrupt
there's almost no difference
between the media in this country and
the hard core stalinists on the left of
the democrat party the aocs the
pressleys the talibs and the omars
they're one and the same they have no
disagreement on issues or tactics or
anything of the kind
we demonstrated last week and we will
demonstrate going forward we don't need
them
we can go around them above them and
under them
but we don't need them hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else